- You sold me out, son.
Now you gonna end up with a
bullet in your head for it.
- You can't play
me, motherfucker.
I'm the motherfucker that plays
motherfuckers, motherfucker.
- Cut!
(bell ringing)
(clearing throat)
- All right everybody,
let's get reset.
We are going again.
(exhaling)
- Nigel, that's great.
- Oh, great, it's smashing,
thank you so much.
It's been an absolute honor.
And what a great
opportunity to be here
and be able to play an
American tough like this.
- I'm just so glad that
we got you out of that
BBC commitment so
you can play with us.
- Cheers, mate, cheers.
(laughing)
- Antoine, listen.
I'm just not buying that
you're someone that was
born and raised in the
streets of Brooklyn.
- That's weird
'cause I actually was
born and raised on the
streets of Brooklyn.
(clearing throat)
I was in a gang and everything.
Most of this stuff
actually happened to me.
- Wow, okay, well
that's great for us
because I want you
to use it, okay?
It was a good first take.
Let's just, uh,
let's get going then.
Let's get going.
- Thank you, Jim.
(clearing throat)
- Scene five, take two.
(bell ringing)
- And action!
- You sold me out, son.
Now you gonna end up with a
bullet in your head for it.
- You can't play
me, motherfucker.
I'm the motherfucker that plays
motherfuckers, motherfucker.
(deep exhale)
- Cut.
(bell ringing)
Cut.
(clearing throat)
Okay, uh, Nigel, that was great.
- Oh!
- Brilliant.
Just the way you move,
especially when you talk,
I just really see this character
coming to life before my eyes.
- Cheers, mate, cheers.
- It's fabulous.
- Antoine, your performance, um,
it's just not quite
there yet, okay?
I really need to
see you make more
of a transformation, okay?
Like, Nigel, here.
- That dude's British.
- Yeah.
- Antoine, if I might jump
in with a bit of advice?
- I don't think I need that.
- No, no, no,
look, hear him out.
- Maybe you might
want to try thinking
of something in the
material that's similar
to something that's
happened in your real life.
For me, for instance,
I like to think of
when my mum wanted me
to attend prep school in
Leeds to become a barrister,
but I wanted to study
the theater at Oxford.
- Thank God.
- And so that was
a conundrum for me.
- I'm gonna stop you right there
because this is
just confusing me.
Right?
Like, I don't need that
'cause I am from the streets.
I was in a gang.
They told me to kill my cousin.
- This might be a
bit spot on, no?
- Yeah, that's a bit spot on.
Do you have any stories
that involve your mum?
- What's a mum?
- Oh, dear.
- Scene five, take three.
(bell ringing)
- Okay, Antoine, remember
you're a gangster, okay?
Betrayal, the streets, okay?
Nigel, you're perfect.
Antoine, transform.
And action!
- You sold me out, son.
Now you gonna get a bullet
up in your head for it.
- You can't play
me, motherfucker.
I'm the motherfucker that plays
motherfuckers, motherfucker.
- He's boring to watch.
(deep exhale)
Cut.
(bell ringing)
- That does not sound good.
(deep exhale)
- Antoine, I do not
feel like you have found
the emotional core
of this character.
- Man, fuck this!
Nobody is more
real than me, okay?
I come from the streets
and nobody's gonna tell me
what the streets is like.
Nobody, you understand?
- That's a great speech, I
just wish that I believed it.
You wanna give it a shot?
- Sure, I'll have a go.
Man, fuck this.
I'm as real as it gets.
- Yes!
- These fucking
streets is for real,
I'm up in there, man.
- You are.
- I'm fucking from the fucking
from the earth
from these streets.
- From the Earth.
- Something to that effect.
- No, but I am so with you.
I am with you when you say that
even when you're
saying the wrong words.
I just wish you could do that.
- You know what?
(blows landing)
(coughing)
- Oh, goodness.
- Okay, that hurts but
I don't feel that it
comes from the right emotional
place for the character.
All right, here give it a shot.
Watch, watch.
(blows landing)
(coughing)
- Oh, that's great!
I feel that in here and
in here in my heart.
- That's very gracious
of you to say that.
- Try that again.
(blow landing)
(coughing)
- I just, I don't,
I don't believe you.